the Fox News Alert it is not a good
night for the Clintons the hills John
Solomon reporting tonight a new
investigation into the Clinton
Foundation has been opened by the FBI
now according to the report
investigators will be looking for any
possible wrongdoing surrounding
pay-to-play
or other illegal activity while Hillary
Clinton was serving as your Secretary of
State also tonight The Daily Beast
reporting the DOJ is looking into
Hillary Clinton's email server John
Solomon Sarah Carter will join us in a
minute here with reaction to the
shocking news as well as tonight's
opening monologue is the former deputy
assistant to the president Potts News
contributor Sebastian Gorka and Fox News
correspondent at-large
apparently co-host of the five now
Geraldo Rivera I'm watching you a week
this is huge news they're now looking in
to the Clinton Foundation and it's now
confirmed they now are are clearly also
now looking into the email server
scandal which we now know Comey
basically rigged with Peter struck
because they got wrote an exoneration
months before the investigation I think
in terms of the email scandal there is
no doubt but that the fix was in
it is also an archaic scandal and if we
go back there again
the eyes of the public will roll into
the back of their head and said oh no
what's next Benghazi the the all the
wait a minute will laws broken in your
view as an attorney they they very well
may Helen II in felonies they may have
been but I don't know what crime it
would be you need intent okay violate
this okay we'll see act so okay so if
you set up a private server in a
mom-and-pop shop bathroom closet wait a
minute you put secret top secret
classified special access below and then
you destroy it to let him leave admit it
as for wash it the room on the reason
the other aspect of this the
pay-for-play Clinton Foundation aspect
of this is much more intriguing is that
it is new we haven't treaded and treaded
and hours and hours ago but you more
than most but I want to know how the
Clintons became so wealthy when they
never had a real job
good questions but if you if you
conflate this with that even all saying
again why why would we ever give old new
20% of America's uranium robert muller
knew the FBI had a spy inside of putin's
ring bribery extortion money laundering
kickback sebastian so then they still
allowed Sophia's to sign off nine zero
across the board and the money went
right back to the Clinton Foundation 150
what billion million dollars huge amis
we've been waiting more more than a year
to find out if America is still a nation
of the rule of law and now Hillary's
gonna find out the answer to her own
question what difference does it make
and here Aldo I didn't know you studied
law but I'll have to tell you something
as a former federal employee intent is
utterly irrelevant when it comes to the
handling of classified materials in
federal law you do not need to be giving
that information to a foreign agent if
you simply misplace it you have
committed a felony it's one of the few
aspects of federal law where intent is
irrelevant and that woman had at least
108 emails at the highest classification
of the federal system on her private
service that's a felony hero this is the
way I totally disagree with the illegal
analysis but let me make it much work
much more important point I care about
the 45th President of the United States
I care about Donald Trump I want his
presidency to be a success
I fear that he is not touting his
strengths as Sean alluded in the opening
of this program we have an economy now
that is robust that is booming that is
including everybody from the wealthy to
the to the person the urban forget
support out back unemployment seven year
low that I want to tell that success I
want to I want to scream that from the
rooftops that positive message is what
the American people are yearning to hear
not Hillary Clinton
what about equal justice what do I care
about Hillary clinical justice under the
law Sebastian what is is is the statue
of Lady Justice blind
hold it for a reason Geraldo all
Americans should be equal before the law
whether your last name is Rivera or
whether your last name is Clinton
this woman has committed felonies it
goes without saying the fact that the
director of the FBI said she had a
hundred and eight classified emails on
her private server that's a felony her
al-ghab and in the last two three years
why hasn't there been any meaningful
that's the question Trump to be droid a
back into that crap again it's not
Donald Trump he has no say in this why
and I ask you this why would call me and
struck a Trump hater be writing an exact
and hang on exoneration months before
they ever even interviewed that the main
people involved with dozens of hostile
eyes on Hillary Clinton's private email
server there has not been one scintilla
of proof that any leak next question
hostile climate 5ro bret baier 99%
certainty five foreign agencies had
access to that next question so you're
telling me is not obstruction of justice
so I have subpoenaed emails 33,000 I
delete hang on then I acid wash and
bleach bit the hard drive and then just
to make sure I take the blackberries and
I smash them with a hammer you're not
telling me that's not intentional
obstruction of justice I am telling you
that even if even as you recited that
with your eloquence my eyes rolled why
because they don't care about Hillary
Clinton Hillary Clinton don't care about
the loss again you care about equal job
care about the president succeeding and
uniting the kids not going to do it or
together no big issues I could worker
every American Heraldo included should
care if federal law enforcement officers
are breaking the law when Hillary
Clinton was interviewed her Sacco
suspect was allowed to act as her
counsel and the FBI not Hillary the FBI
destroyed the lab
tops that was central to that
investigation here Aldo you should care
about that because that means we've got
my future not the past
dr. gore crime was committed against
your daughter ten years ago would you
care about that person you show me one
victim from that whole email baloney
America America's national security the
American agents picked up on it although
like what we're intelligent we're like a
CIA document that says that I I don't oh
boy
alright we're gonna have to leave it
there